We've been talking about array lists up to now and array lists are very
flexible, but there are times when arrays are lower level construct are more
useful. Here is how to make an array of values of type double. As you can see,
it looks quite different than the declaration of an array list, so let's take
it apart. Over here is the type, it's an array indicated by these brackets of
double. This is the variable. Here's the new operator and back here we say we
want to construct an array of ten doubles, so as you can see you put the length
of the array inside the brackets, unlike with arrayLists, the size of an array
can never change, this array here has been made with ten numbers and it'll
always have ten numbers in it. No more and no less. There's a second way of
constructing an array that's often very convenient. Here I have again an array
of floating point numbers. I call it moreValues. And over here I simply put
enclosed inside braces the values that I want to put in the array. This array
has length five and again it'll always have length five.